y la garra ucrania sigue estremeciendo
al mundo esta familia salvó su vida por
casualidad llegaron minutos después de
que un misil golpeara la estación del
tren de crematorio en el este de ucrania
lugar clave de las fuerzas rusas para
hacerse con la región del donbass uno de
los últimos ataques que ha dejado
decenas de muertos y heridos la familia
sidorenko que esperaba poder huir de
ucrania cuenta como sobrevivió
chivas estoy muy bien con estas fechas y
vamos a subir al tren de evacuación
previsto a las 11 de la mañana llamamos
a un taxi pero no llegó a tiempo y
tuvimos que esperar otro y finalmente
llegamos a la estación de tren tres
minutos después de la explosión y vimos
vehículos quemados restos del misil
quemado y personas huyendo de allí
mientras tanto cerca de la capital kiev
los residentes de autoridades regresan a
ver lo que queda de sus hogares de
muchos la ciudad que ha dejado
paralizado al planeta ante las escenas
de violencia registradas luego de la
retirada de las tropas rusas en este
momento solo cocinamos alimentos en
troncos y llueve como se puede cocinar
en troncos personalmente no tengo nada
para calentar mi comida desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa o crear el 24 de
febrero ambas naciones han
responsabilizado de los ataques a
civiles en medio de la guerra por su
parte el presidente ucraniano ha
calificado estos últimos hechos como
crímenes de guerra y exigido una
respuesta mundial contra rusia al tiempo
las autoridades rusas acusan a ucrania
de atacar a sus propios ciudadanos